what is the kgb
right so that is the committee of uh
state security yeah business partners
this is a a personalist is a threat
right threat okay and yes means without
right
and i guess that directly translates to
security without threat so and
don't don't exist anymore it was
disbanded when the soviet union fell
apart and
the successor agencies were are now the
svr and and the fsb
fsb supposedly the equivalent to the fbi
and svr the cia but
the svr is relatively weak
and the fsb has has taken on a lot of
espionage and
you know
active measures and they're much bigger
and stronger but the most
capable intelligence agency in russia is
the is the gru military intelligence
then nobody knows very much that's right
i when i was in the kgb i had no idea
that there was military intelligence
nobody ever mentioned anything like that
and by the way i recently had a
pleasure to give a talk at the dia
when they reached out to me i didn't
know they existed either interesting
yeah that's always the question if you
want to be an intelligence agency should
the world know anything about you
because in some sense
you want to create the legend in order
to attract
uh great competent individuals to work
for you
but at the same time
you want it to be shrouded in complete
mystery if nobody knows you exist you
might be able to operate
well as an intelligence agency that that
is fascinating but fsb is the thing that
carries the flag right of
of kgb kgb being
probably one of if not the most
sort of infamous famous infamous and
powerful intelligence agencies
in history yes ever absolutely 100
it was founded in 1954 after the death
of stalin
you've uh in writing your book looked
back at the predecessors of the history
right is there some way in which
the kgb
is grounded
in
the culture the spirit the soul
of its predecessors oh absolutely they
just changed names and they changed
uh personnel rather frequently and that
had something to do with stalin's
paranoia
from between
1923 and i don't remember what
i think it may have been the nkvd at
that time it started as a chicka and
then it became the
the gepi gpu the uh
three or four letters
yes
but with those name changes you also had
changes at the top
between 1923 and 1953 when stalin died
that is uh 30 years they had eight heads
of uh intelligence
and of of those eight
six were executed when they were
replaced so that's an um
that's an indication that uh you know
this was an organization that ate itself
from the inside
the soviet union was the only
dictatorship in history that did not
rest its powers on the military they
rested its powers on the intelligence
apparatus and that thing was unstable so
you know
where that leads eventually if you rest
your your power on something that is
made out of bricks that don't hold a lot
of load it will it will fall apart
on sand yeah why was it unstable would
you say what what of human nature
or did that make sense it's the paranoia
it's you know stalin was always worried
about
uh you know what the the most powerful
people coming after him
so he proactively killed off heads of
the kgb and uh and he had this great
purge where he got rid of a lot of his
generals you know really capable
generals
uh and uh that that cost him dearly when
world war ii started because you know he
he started off with uh
with a uh uh force that wasn't as
capable as it could have been uh was it
paranoid at all levels i believe so i
believe so
it comes from the top and so if the top
doesn't trust you
uh you always have to worry about
um
your peers
snitching on you yeah okay so so and and
i think we have a very similar situation
in russia today
uh and uh and and in this in in this
kind of atmosphere
um the truth
will never get to the top so no matter
what moral rules the organization
operates under trust is fundamental to
its uh
competence oh absolutely and i want to
extend this to my own existence
um
and this is kind of strange it's it's
almost dichotomous uh
because you know i was
running around lying to everybody and
you know i couldn't fundamentally be
trusted but the relationship that i had
with the kgb was based on trust if they
don't if they don't trust me they don't
send me out
and if i don't trust them i'm not going
and i eventually broke that trust
and they knew there was always that
danger
they knew that because something about
you
or just something about human beings no
there were
there were hints about uh
uh you know how long
my assignment would be so 10 to 12 years
and you see
it makes sense all right i was becoming
an american and over time i would become
more and more american and there was
always a chance
that i liked it more here than there
that that i was really successful in
what i was supposed to do
and it sort of happened but in my case
it happened because of i fathered a
child who
who i didn't want to leave when they
wanted me back so love always screws up
oh
your employment competence yes you're
absolutely right
yes so that but they thought you know
that
i had an anchor at home because i had a
wife and a son at home which
uh you know you've got to worry about
them
if you defect
uh because
in the past the kgb was would go after
after family
ruthlessly
including perhaps violence
yeah this is a hard question about the
kgb because it's one of the most
ruthless organizations but in general
um are there lines
kgb
agents
at every level of the hierarchy
that they would not cross
political legal ethical
or does anything goes to achieve the
goal
i was only uh
in touch with the two types of agents as
whether the technical experts the ones
that taught me tradecraft
uh and they were like engineers and uh
you know they were in charge of the
secret writing and the uh
uh the morse
code shortwave radio and reception
decryption encryption and that kind of
stuff um
those were just doing their job
all right
and the others the ones that trained me
that
prepared me for life in the united
states
they were nice people
they were elegant people
i i i don't think they that they would
not uh
um
fit into the stereotype of the ruthless
gun carrying agent
is it possible
that you would not be aware of the parts
of the kgb
i mean it's very modular would you yeah
it's possible that you're not aware of
the parts of the kgb that that are the
quote-unquote muscle oh
i didn't know i would find out
afterwards after i you know retired and
then started doing some research i had
no clue you're kind of operating in a
bubble oh very much so i mean this is
what the kgb did really really well
compartmentalization
uh and and that uh
was based on
you know the communist movement while it
was still underground
you know the cells were very small
and the so that maybe there were three
four members in one cell that knew one
another and then they had a liaison to
another cell so with
the bottom line is if you got one one of
those folks were caught
they could maybe betray four people or
three something like that and and the
kgb
continued with that tradition
uh i have reason to believe that the my
handler the person in moscow that sort
of directed me and made decisions uh
what to do and where to go
never met me personally
there's no reason to right why would
so uh in in this this uh actually uh was
a big advantage uh over other
intelligence services because you know
you look at what the cia does everybody
blabs
there's a lot of leaks coming out of
american intelligence i don't think
there's as many leaks coming out of uh
the mossad strong words from jack
so i mean that is a question i want to
ask a little more systematically is
there something unique about the kgb
compared to the other intelligence
agencies let's let's talk
uh the british intelligence mi6
mossad cia
is there unique cultures
spirits souls of the different
organizations that maybe somehow connect
to the structures of government connect
maybe the
the values of the people those kinds of
things i believe we were all pretty much
uh uh strong
uh believers in communism in the future
of the world being in kgb yes
i think that that unified us
to a large degree even the technicians
so even
it wasn't
something like yeah yeah the
the parents believe this thing
but we know the truth you really believe
the story of conor absolutely did and
you need to look at the time frame
uh
the soviet union uh after world war ii
made uh quite a bit of progress in uh
influencing the third world and i still
remember uh in when i was in middle
school
we had a map
on the map of the world and it was
color-coded
so red was communism that was the soviet
union and then the eastern states and
then blue was uh capitalism and then
then we had green which were the third
world countries and the green
slowly turned pink because a lot of
third world governments like i'm looking
at angola
i'm looking at uh um
vietnam
a lot of these countries uh were uh very
sympathetic to to the soviet union and
so we
sort of knew that this would go on like
that and eventually we would take over
and and you know pretty much
uh overtake
that was that that was the the myth
overtake the united states
not only militarily but also
in terms of industrial production and
and so forth
that was a stupid pipe dream the
military
it was a standoff as we know
well
uh stupid pipe dream
um hitler had a
stupid pipe dream yeah that he executed
it exceptionally effectively and on
if not for
uh
a handful of military mistakes the world
could look very different the biggest
one being invading
the soviet union particularly at the
time that he did it because he ran into
the same thing that
napoleon ran into
general winter
while within so operation barbarossa
within that
he could have made different
decisions
yeah for example uh
attacking
skipping kiev and attacking moscow
directly overthrowing the government so
marching i guess that that would be
learning the lessons from napoleon as
opposed to
um
as opposed to a different kind of
distribution of forces and then getting
bogged down in the winter but the point
is
these ambitions sometimes do
you know the ambitions of empire
sometimes do materialize in the growth
and the building and the establishment
of those empires and those empires write
the history books
in such a way that we don't think of
them as as empires or we certainly don't
think of them as the bad guys
they write the history books therefore
they're the good guys
you